I think it's more of a problem the
United States than it is other places
and there's some places where science is
less of an issue and there's a place
where face is less of an issue but in
the United States it's very nicely ducks
to pose and I think it's actually a very
good dynamic I think if I were what I
would I think part of the problem is
there's a tendency to focus on the
extremes it's it makes for good press
and for book sales and so forth and I
think there's a lot more need for
meeting in the middle which is finding
ways that you can if you really don't
know something just admit you don't know
something if you don't know for sure
that you can't rule out an intelligent
designer then teach it in schools what
if you if science is so fragile that
they can't teach exactly how you would
question things and discover things and
I think we need to work on that make it
much less fragile so I think it's a it
could become a healthy dialogue right
now it's not healthy because of focusing
on the extremes and not trying really
hard to get people engaged
I mean people should be engaged in it
more than just a gut reaction they
should actually want to if even if there
is an intelligent design agenda that
should be deeply informed about science
about technology about how you actually
answer questions I think that that a lot
of what we have are a set of accidents
and there is design in the world and
there will be lots of design going
forward and it's an opportunity to to
embrace both the natural and the
synthetic there's a lot of a lot of
what's natural is painful and a lot of
what's synthetic is not completely
thought out but offers an alternative
and I and I my worldview is that it's
that dynamic between design and past and
future and the parts of nature that we
like in the parts of nature which for
one reason or other because of say
population explosion is still natural
but
Barents it's pathological from our human
viewpoint and we need to embrace ecology
in a very intelligent way and this
requires that our politicians and
regular folks know great deal more about
ecology in their world and their in
their personal diversity than they
currently know I think that for science
and religious science has very definite
faith components and most religions
don't stick to faith they venture out
into making predictions about our
physical world they don't just say
there's something that is completely
unconnected to us they say actually it
affects our lives and when they do that
they merge they they they have there's a
we know that our that the part of that
are there is a connection between our
feelings and our brain our brain is a
scientific something that we could study
scientifically so I think there's they
can and should coexist there's a lot of
faith that's expressed by scientists
about science it's kind of an act of
faith that science is a good thing we
don't know that for sure we won't know
that we may not know that millions of
years from now I mean so and by good
thing we can even even phrasing goodness
in a scientific context like survival of
the species would be something that
probably scientists would agree is a
good thing
we won't know whether science is a good
thing for the survival of species rather
than having entirely faced base so I
think these things are there they are
solvable they are addressable we can
bring them together but it requires less
extreme views what would benefit
you